نحن نتواجد في مدينه دوه جنوب الخليل
وتحديدا في هذا المنزل الذي انسحب منه
جنود الاحتلال قبل حوالي نصف ساعه الى
ساعه ويظهر في هذه الصوره كما تشاهدون هذا
الخراب الكبير الذي خلفه الاحتلال في منزل
المواطن شامخ النموره الذي كما ذكرنا
اقتحم الاحتلال منزله وقام بتفتيش المنزل
ووضع العائله مجتمعه في مكان واحد وم كف
الاحتلال اكثر من ساعتين في هذا المنزل
وقام بتفتيشه تفتيشا دقيقا وخلف كما يظهر
في هذه الصوره هذا الخراب الكبير في
المنزل قبل ان يقوم الاحتلال باعتقال
المواطن النموره واقتياده ل جهه مجهوله
طبعا خلال الاقتحام لهذا المنزل اندلعت
مواجهات بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال في
دوره اسفرت عن اصابه شاب بالرصاص الحي في
منطقه الكتف اصابته وصفت بال المتوسطه نقل
الى المشفى لتلقي العلاج و تزامن مع
اقتحام دوره جنوب الخليل تزامن مع ذلك
اقتحام مناطق متفرقه من المحافظه تحديدا
في يطا جنوب الخليل اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
مدينه يطا وداهمت احد المنازل وفتشته كما
جرى في هذا المنزل اضافه الى اقتحام بلده
بتمر شمال الخليل وتفتيش عدد كبير من
المنازل في البلده في بلده بتمر و كان
هناك استجوابا وتحقيقا ميدانيا مع
المواطنين كان هناك اقتحام ايضا ل مدينه
الخليل منطقه باب الزاويه بئر المحجر
نتحدث ايضا عن اقتحام لمخيم الفوار جنوب
الخليل قوات الاحتلال داهمت المخيم باعداد
كبيره من جنود الاحتلال وفتشت منازل
المواطنين في المخيم وكذلك ايضا كان هناك
مداهمه وتفتيش لمنازل المواطنين كما ذكرنا
في وسط مدينه الخليل وفي المنطقه الجنوبيه
ايضا التي اقتحمها الاحتلال وفتش عدد من
المنازل نشوان هذه الصوره التي تض ظهر
امامنا وهذا الخراب الكبير في هذا المنزل
هذه هي الصوره التي تتكرر بشكل يومي في
بيوت ومنازل الفلسطينيين الذي التي يتم
اقتحامها من قبل قوات الاحتلال حيث تخلف
هذا الدمار الكبير في هذه المنازل كما
ايضا نتحدث عن الاعتداء يعني هذا صاحب هذا
المنزل هذا المواطن الذي تم اعتقاله هذه
الليله كما علمنا من العائله قبل قليل تم
الاعتداء عليه قبل ان يقوم جنود الاحتلال
باعتقاله حتى ان جنود الاحتلال خطوا
شعارات تلمود على يعني باب هذا المنزل
وعلى البوابه الرئيسيه المؤديه اليه ايضا
ووصل الامر بجنود الاحتلال الى تفتيش يعني
حتى المجاري الداخليه في هذا المنزل تم
تفتيشها لم يترك جنود الاحتلال شيء في هذا
البيت الا وقام بتفتيشه وخلف كما ذكرنا
هذا الدمار الكبير طبعا هذا ياتي في اطار
حملات المداهمه والاقتحامات المستمره
والمتواصل
في مناطق الضفه الغربيه وهذه الحالات
الكبيره من الاعتقال وصل عدد المعتقلين
حسب احصائيه نادي الاسير يوم امس يعني لا
تشمل معتقلي هذه الليله
4795 حاله اعتقال سجلها نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني الخليل لوحدها حيث نحن نتواجد
سجلت اعلى حالات الاعتقال 1100 حاله
اعتقال من الخليل لوحدها 29 سيده تم
اعتقالهم في الخليل ايه افرج عن جزء كبير
منهن سبعه لازلنا رهن الاعتقال حتى هذه
اللحظه وهذه الصوره التي نحن بصدد نقلها
الان من هذا المنزل هي صوره متكرره
متشابهه في الخليل وفي غيرها من المحافظات
وهذه الصوره التي يتركها جنود الاحتلال
بعد اقتحام منازل المواطنين التي يتم
اقتحامها نشوان بهذا الشكل وبهذه الطريقه
كما يظهر في هذه الصوره